I'm going to be talking about logarithms
logarithms to the base 10 so for example
if I have a number which is a hundred I
can think of that as 10 squared or 10
whoops
to the power 2 so 2 is the logarithm of
this number 100 to the base 10 a
thousand is 10 to the 3 that's this is
the logarithm the 3 and it corresponds
to the number of zeros there it is
logarithm of a thousand equals 3 I can
do 10 to another number so for example
10 to the 1 point 6 2 3 2 turns out to
be 42 that means that if I were to take
10 that means that the log to the base
10 of 42 is 1 point 6 2 3 2 2 4
significant figures the reason it's
useful is multiplication if I have two
numbers and I want to multiply them
together it's easy to make mistakes
because there are a lot of little
operations that have to be added up if
you go through logarithms and you get a
logarithm of a number such as 42 and you
multiply it with another number such as
3759 or 200 you get the logarithm of
that number and you add these numbers
together let me show you an example 37
times 59 now I can write 37 as 10 to the
one point five six eight two and
multiply that by this number which is 10
to the power one point seven seven oh
nine and when I multiply these numbers
together but all I have to do is add
this number to that number to make this
into 10 to the three point three three
nine one that's like a shortcut yes
instead of multiplying numbers you are
adding this to that to get this exponent
and that number it turns out is two one
eight three instead of having to write
this out longhand as 37 times 59 and
work it all out in gory detail
which will require nine times seven and
three times nine and then 5 times seven
and and working it out and not making a
mistake
all you have to do is addition which is
much easier and if I were to do division
I would do subtraction which is much
easier addition and subtraction are much
easier than multiplication division so
this is a great simplification it makes
your life much easy the catch is that
you have to know these numbers 37 is 10
to the power of this so where did I get
that from where did I get 59 is this
number well the big secret the thing
that makes it possible is that I have a
table of these logarithms and I look up
37 this is actually 3.7 so in order to
make it 37 I have to add a 1 to it and
it's one point five six eight two so
that's this number and then I look up 59
and there's 59 59 point naught I go
across it's point seven 709 but this is
five point nine so I have to add a 1 so
these I cheated it's all in a table I
could look it up when I was a lad at
school this is how we learn to do
multiplication I mean we learn how to do
long multiplication but we added these
numbers together to get the answer
quickly and it was the way of doing it
because there weren't pocket calculators
in my youth because I'm so old this is
all we add down mind so when I've got
this number I have to go to a different
table which is called the table of anti
logs now the three in the front of this
means a thousand so I just have to look
up point three three nine one so I go
down the table there is point three
three and then you look across the top
and there's a nine three three nine one
two one eight three and then I look at
the one which is this thing and add that
and you see I get to one eight three and
if there was a number there I'd have to
add that last one but it's actually zero
so this is two one eight three which
turns out to be the right answer exactly
so you could get four significant
figures by doing this which is
reasonably accurate
it's the speed the reliability if these
tables are accurate you can get the
numbers that's just something that
school boys and school girls would use
over the log table is important in
professionals oh yes log tables will be
used by professionals who wanted to get
accuracy and they might not be just four
significant figures they might be more
depending on the accuracy of the
calculations that you need to make and
they made calculations very reliable
provided the tables were reliable but
the tables to start with weren't very
reliable and that's that's really a
complete story in itself which I like to
tell you well now you're going to ask
the question where do these numbers come
from how did I make up tables anti
logarithms and logarithms and this was
done by a man called John Napier